we spent some time reporting on this
story we should have spent a lot more
time
because this could be the most
consequential thing to happen to this
country to this world maybe ever
in june the united states government is
set to release a public report on
everything it knows about ufos lou
elizondo is the former head of the
advanced aerospace threat identification
program he's been on the show a number
of times
he just spoke to the new york post about
what that report will show
according to lasando we will find
an intelligence failure on the part of
the u.s intel community
on the level of 9 11.
the last time we had an intelligence
failure of this country a major one
which was 9 11 it took us almost three
years to come up with the 911 commission
report
okay takes a long time um let's just go
down the rabbit hole here for a second
let's just assume this is some sort of
adversarial or foreign technology that
several decades now has managed to leave
progress and evade all 18 members of the
intelligence community despite our best
human intelligence signals intelligence
imagery intelligence
yada yada yada yada right um that would
be an intelligence failure
that would eclipse just about anything
else this country has ever faced
especially this has occurred for decades
that there's a foreign adversary that
can put
a nuclear warhead within moments over
washington dc
okay that's that's a problem yeah
that's a problem and too few have
considered it from that perspective
nick pope is a former ministry of
defense
official from the uk and perfectly
positioned
to answer the obvious question which is
why didn't we see this coming he joins
us now nick thanks so much
for coming on i thought lou made a very
solid point and i'm embarrassed i hadn't
thought of it before which is this is
among other
things whatever these objects are a
potentially
very grave threat to nation states so
where was the intelligence community
in warning about this and learning more
about it
where were they
well that has to be answered absolutely
i mean we are under siege
it's like there's a war of nerves going
on
and uh if if this was drones
belonging to a foreign adversary there
would be an absolute outcry
and yet the situation we're in that we
don't know what these things are and
they might even be extraterrestrial
that's worse so i agree with luis
elizondo on this this is a
potential catastrophic failure of
intelligence
and if it happened because skeptical
bureaucrats
were just saying to themselves it can't
be therefore it isn't
then there must be a reckoning so you
say and
and that is such a great point and
nicely put but you described it as a
siege
give our viewers who don't follow this
topic closely a sense of
the magnitude of data coming in about
these encounters
yeah i mean this is absolutely
extraordinary and
every day it seems like new information
drops things that the public and the
media weren't told
so for example former director of
national intelligence john ratcliffe
just threw into the conversation the
other day the fact that the satellite
imagery of all this and some of the
speeds
being reported seem to blow the theory
about
foreign drones out of the water we must
be told what's going on here and we
should think of this
upcoming report to congress as an
intelligence assessment of the
phenomenon itself
and one that's long overdue
there are a lot of these this is not
like you know some drunk guy in a rural
road in northern new hampshire
saw something weird i mean this is the
u.s military regularly
very often recording these objects
yes absolutely it's pilots it's radar
operators
it's satellite data it's measurement and
signature intelligence there's
such a lot of information now so much
that the us
navy has instructions for its pilots on
what to do if they encounter
these things now i think as we go into
may
and the run-up to this report going to
congress there's going to be a lot of
things going on behind the scenes a lot
of politicking jockeying for position
factions uh trying to to kind of have
their say on this
i anticipate more leaks of information
photos
videos documents uh there's a lot more
to come here
nick pope has been on this for so long i
appreciate your
steadfast commitment to answering
obvious questions what is this
thank you good to see you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else